hello and welcome back to my channel my
name is samuel leeds and i'm a property
investor and in this video you're going
to be learning the three ways to make
money from property if you enjoy my
channel please do add me a massive favor
and subscribe to the youtube channel
turn the notification bell on and also
don't forget to smash that like button
so how do you make money from property
when you're an a property investor well
the first thing is to acknowledge that
when you're buying a property
the sole purpose of a property
investment is to make
money when a lot of people buy
properties they mix their emotions and
their feelings into the purchase
if you're a home buyer and you're buying
a house to live in you're going to look
at all the different factors of what's
the garden like what's the color of the
house do i like the feel of it what's
the neighbors like where are the nearest
schools would my children like these
schools and there's hundreds and
hundreds of different factors into your
purchase decision
however when you're buying a property as
an investment you need to be saying does
it tick the three boxes and every single
box boils down to the money now some
people might be thinking samuel
it's not all about the money however it
is all about the money because when
you're buying a property as an
investment you have to make a financial
decision and you have to purchase with
your formulas not with your feelings not
with your emotions so what are the three
ways that a property investment makes
you money it's very very very simple the
first way that property makes money is
when you buy a property over time it is
likely to appreciate in value over time
now the reason the property goes up in
value over time is because there's
limited supply in the in
the country there's only so much land
available in any given country and when
there's a limited amount of something it
holds its value especially when it's a
necessity and houses and land is a
necessity we have an overpopulation of
people on the planet and we have a
shortage of houses and a shortage of
land on average property prices double
in value every 10 years so when you buy
a property you need to look at the
capital appreciation of that property
now some people have argued with me on
this and have said samuel property
property prices do not double in value
every 10 years they've said this is
completely untrue however
i would urge you to do your own research
and look at the last 10 and the 10
before that and the 10 before that and
the 10 before that and the 10 before
that and you will see the pattern is
that properties really do
double in value on average every 10
years
now many people say
hmm maybe they did in the past but i
don't think that's going to happen over
the next 10. well guess what that's
exactly what people were saying 10 years
ago i bought my first property
investment in birmingham in 2009
just after the crash and everybody was
telling me that it was not going to
double over the next 10 years that was
then this is now guess what's happened
it doubled within 10 years it's now
worth 200 000 pounds so that is the
first way that you are going to make
money from investing in property now
this is something that is you could
argue is a little bit out of your
control
it may happen over time it may not you
can't rely on capital appreciation to
pay your bills which is why there's two
other ways that property makes money by
the way if you're enjoying the video so
far please don't forget to hit the like
button that would really really help me
out the second way that you make money
in property is of course
via the rent
now when you buy a property you're going
to try and make sure that you get as
much rent as possible
how are you going to do this are you
going to do this by forcing the rents up
and being a really greedy landlord and
charging a really high rent and and
screwing over your tenants of course not
you're going to do this by buying a
property in an area that is popular that
has a high demand that tenants are
wanting to rent so instead of when
looking at houses thinking about how you
feel about the house instead you should
ask how will tenants feel about the
house what are letting agencies local to
the area saying the rent will be and you
need to make sure that your rent is
going to cover all of the expenses of
owning the house namely the mortgage
payments the management the maintenance
void periods and you're going to need to
make sure that you're left with a nice
profit on that property every single
month that is what you call your passive
income
your passive income is going to make you
financially free and the capital
appreciation of the house is what's
going to make you rich and that's how
many people have become
accidental millionaires
however there is still a third way to
make money when buying property and the
third way is by buying a property below
market value if there's a house that's
worth a hundred thousand pounds and you
buy it for eighty thousand pounds
you have just made
twenty thousand pounds in equity
you have just added twenty thousand
pounds to your net worth and the great
thing about property is it's not like
bitcoin or gold or silver where the
price is fixed you can find motivated
sellers that are in a rush to sell and
you can buy it below market value and
add to your net worth and make money
from the discount of the property now
again is this ethical is it ethical to
find people that are in a really bad
situation maybe they're in dire straits
and they need to sell their house
quickly is it ethical for you to come
along and to agree to buy at a cheap
price
well in business you always need a
willing buyer and a willing seller so if
someone's in a rush to sell their
property because they're about to go
repossessed or maybe they're about to
move abroad and they need the money to
buy their second home they've got a job
career change or whatever it may be you
need to remember you're actually helping
that person move on in their life and
because you're helping them move on
quickly and promptly in their life
your reward is you're getting a discount
this is win win
everything in business has to be win win
a willing buyer and a willing seller and
that is how most businesses in fact
pretty much all businesses make money
and become successful so those are the
three ways that you can make money in
property by
waiting for the property to go up in
value someone once said don't wait to
buy land buy land and wait
the second way is by renting the
property out and receiving a passive
income from the rental of that property
and the third way is by buying at a
discount below market value and adding
to your net worth from the discount of
the property i hope you enjoyed this
video if you want to see more videos
like this then don't forget to subscribe
to the channel i also i show you around
one of my students house in a video and
i can show you how one of my students
made 400 thousand pounds profit on one
property deal very very quickly as well
within a matter of months i really think
you'd enjoy that video if you want to
watch it you can check it out right over
here and of course don't forget to
subscribe to the channel hit the like
button and i will see you over on the
next video